- [Cha] If you make
$1,000 a week be happy
with your $1,000 a week.
Don't look at the
next person and say,
"Well, he's making $10."
Gratitude is an
unlocker, my man.
400 trillion to 1.
I just want
everybody to hear this.
This is the reason
I'm happy 24/7/365
for the rest of my life.
400 trillion to 1,
the odds of
becoming a human being.
You might not like the human
being situation you ended up in
but let me tell you this.
You're mom might've
grabbed another glass of wine
and you never would have been.
(Cha laughs)
I mean 400 trillion to 1.
You're more likely to
win the lottery of over
$100 million nine
times in your life
than being Rick.
- [Cha] And that's
why I tell people
it's a privilege to be here.
- And of course,
everybody's gonna say,
well that's the thing, right?
"I'm not born in America."
"I'm an immigrant."
"I'm black."
"I'm a girl."
There's ceilings and
I hate talking about this stuff
as a white man 'cause
I get it, I get it but
it doesn't change tomorrow.
You leaving a
comment on Instagram,
"Easy for you
to say, white boy."
Doesn't change your shit.
(Cha laughs)
- [Envy] Right.
- It doesn't change your shit.
And this white boy's like,
"Here, I'm gonna
try to help you."
There's plenty of black
girls aren't gonna help you.
There's plenty of aliens,
not gonna help you.
I'm trying to help.
It's free.
- [Envy] Now how far are you...